good morning to you the viewers we are
here in the CBS this morning Toyota
greenroom with the 2018 National Teacher
of the Year what's her name Mandy
Manning she was chosen by the nonprofit
Council of Chief state school officers
based on her very effective work inside
the class we should tell you what does
Mandy teach what do you teach Mandy
I teach brand-new immigrant and refugee
students to our nation she teaches
English and math to refugee and
immigrant students at where'd he teach
Mandy
Joel Affairs High School in Spokane
Spokane Washington she is often the
first teacher they have when they come
to this country and we thank you so much
for joining us so this is what I want
you guys to know about Mandy already
she's a teacher but I figured she has to
be a mom because when I walked in she
goes you have spots on your dress
and I said yep this is what happens when
you're walking and you're eating salad
and dressing and she goes is that
balsamic I go yes it is balsamic
dressing so viewers I am aware Kati my
assistant said Gail you look a mess this
is what happens when you're walking
eating brushing to you so I apologize
for my parents but no time to change but
I was so excited to talk to you
it looks like a pattern because there's
so much of it yeah I'm kind of like
Pigpen in the peanut skeleton I know I
got to work on that but listen we are
here to talk about you because
congratulations
so how did you find out you were Teacher
of the Year you get a phone call and I
what I got a phone call and they said hi
Mandy and I was like hi why are you guys
calling me and they were like well we
wanted you to know that you were
selected as the National Teacher of the
Year and I was like and what does it
mean to you Mandy winning that because
listen your competition is very tough
because you're competing against all of
the top teachers in the country what
does it mean to you winning Teacher of
the Year that is you well I first want
to say that it's not a competition it's
a selection because we are it's like
election really I all very good
surrounded by it's incredible educators
but for me being selected as National
Teacher of the Year means that my
students get to get their stories out
there I get to be that ambassador or the
you know the person that shares that
voice for that and that's so so
important and this morning on CBS this
morning we heard from some of your
students who talked very highly of you
who said that you have changed their
lives that they feel that you are
someone that they could talk to because
many of them do not speak English so
there is a language barrier and many of
them have been through very tough things
yes yes my students have been through
some give us some examples of what these
students have been through and how
you've helped them work with them well
my favorite story is Hussein because
he's the one that cuts my hair and he
cuts your hair yes so he came to the
United States in 2012 and he was when he
came originally he was 19 but before the
school year started he turned 20 and so
he came to the newcomer center and the
newcomer Center is for brand-new
immigrant refugee students so they've
not had any you know English before and
so he had one like one year how we'll go
to school he's now he's 24 because you
teach high school students mm-hmm so he
was 20 when he came in so I here's this
kid and he was amazing just to start off
with cuz he was really Creek area sand
he like so interested in meeting people
and practicing his English and it was so
cute and but he was 20 and so I had to
think well what can we do for this
student because he's older than he's
older and he has exactly one year to do
something and so I just you know we
would have conversations together and I
found out that he back in Iraq because
he's from Iraq that he was a butcher and
he also had cut hair for the u.s. army
and I was just like oh my gosh she well
gee did you enjoy that work did you
enjoy cutting hair and he said yeah and
I said well do you want to study that
here and he goes yes it's my dream I
want to be a stylist and I said oh so
how did it come that he cut your hair
did you say would you like to cut my
hair or you wear he said can I cut your
hair well it's a very unusual haircut
man yes so it was several years later
because that year we studied you know I
got him into the skill center and then
he and I worked together to get him
through that first year of cosmetology
school but then a couple of years after
that he went to a local cosmetology
school and he ended up getting his
license and
at the time when he got his license I
had hair like down to here
yeah really long hair and I was like
okay the same your license and I left it
in his hands and Wow and you go from
here down to your chest to this so you
looked in the mirror and you thought oh
you thought hey this is awesome I wanted
to do this and I mean he does a
beautiful job and he recently moved to
San Diego so no this is a cool this is a
haircut that a lot of the cool kids are
wearing super colder weather yes this
morning would do if I came to work with
my hair cut like that anybody in the
room yeah they're going do it do it yeah
then I'll be on West 57th Street going
taxi but when did you know that you
wanted to be a teacher and what is it
that you love so much you're growing up
and your dream was to be a teacher when
did this happen you thought I want to do
this well it wasn't actually until I was
in the classroom that I was like this is
what I do what is it that you saw in the
classroom that made you think I want to
do this well it was this so I got my
degrees in filmmaking oh no I used to
work for a news station and yeah what
did you do
I was this studio tech I was behind the
camera okay but so but I knew that my
personality wasn't quite there quite the
right match for TV news because I just
might match more student to being a
teacher and so I went through all of
these things and then I ended up I
landed in a classroom and I didn't I
didn't have a degree or a certification
but I had a classroom you didn't have
him it is all these degrees I had a
filmmaking degree I see okay they did
not have a degree in education okay
and so but my aunt who when I was in
Texas at the time and she was like you
could totally be a teacher cuz I'd been
in the Peace Corps and I had worked as a
pair of educator for a year in special
education and I was like oh okay I'll
try and I got up so yeah but what is it
that you like about teachers yeah so the
first day I went into the classroom and
I looked out at my students and I was
like oh my gosh I looked at them and I
could they're they were so full of life
and so you know full of potential I will
write you I get high school high school
okay and I was like I get to impact
these kids I get to be here
and I get to make a difference and it
was amazing because I think that having
a purpose mm-hmm is so it's so
fulfilling and then to stand in front of
the kids and realize that my purpose was
to help them be the best that they could
be mm-hmm and so yeah from the first day
in the classroom where it was actually
my classroom I was like yeah this is
what I want to do everybody always says
you know we should say when she was in
the green room but before she was on the
air people were coming up shaking your
hand saying I had a teacher who changed
my life I so admire what you do do you
have a teacher that changed your life
yes I mean I could name my teachers from
the time I was in kindergarten all the
way through high school but the one
teacher who was completely
transformative was mrs. Baker
she was my seventh grade English teacher
in seventh grade I mean middle school
just junior high is tough because it's
really tough for girls there's crazy
things happenin all here and I you know
I was like 5 foot 11 so tall and so you
know I went into the and I was had moved
so I was not even and I moved from
Washington to California and so I didn't
have any friends I didn't know anybody
and I walk into this classroom and
there's miss Baker and she was like I
just knew she wanted me to be there she
was excited to get to know me and it
made the venoms Oh completely committee
you know teachers are certainly in the
forefront now in the news you know today
is the 20th 19th anniversary of
Columbine so a lot of us are thinking
about that terrible day shooting at the
school and I wonder do you feel in
danger when you're at school you know
there's a national conversation about
whether teachers should be armed in the
classroom do you feel that I you know
there's a certain feeling of fear you
know anytime anytime that you're you
know there's a potential for something
to happen but I never feel about in your
classroom no I never think about that in
my classroom I only it when an incident
occurs then we're like all a heightened
heightened awareness but I for one never
ever want to be to be armed and the
reason is because like a class
is a community and if I had a weapon on
me and my students knew that I had a
weapon on me or even if they didn't but
they knew some teachers were armed it
would completely change the dynamic of
classroom how so well classrooms are all
about connections and if a kid knows
that you have a weapon on them and that
you are prepared to use that on a young
person even if it's not them that
completely changes the dynamic between
you because it's no longer this true
true connection of that kind of becomes
like family it's more like well I know
deep down you don't really trust me
mm-hm and I I can't imagine that being a
positive in any way because classrooms
are all about connections yes they're
about content and teaching academics but
so much more important than that is the
relationships that we build and we help
I make connections with the kids and I
help them make connections with each
other and having a weapon in the
classroom is in no way going to make it
more comfortable but you know Mandy I
always wonder what it's like for
teachers and students today because when
I was a kid growing up never in a
million years do you think your life is
in danger at school you know at the very
least I think we would write notes that
we're talking about people you know we
weren't even physically hitting each
other and now it's gone from physically
hitting each other to possibly losing
your life yeah so you don't go into
school every day thinking this could be
the day or even in the back of your mind
on some level that's not something that
you carry with you I will say that in
incidents like us an incident like a
school shooting is one florida that we
worst nightmare like worst nightmare
scenario and and i can't say that i
never think about that because i i mean
i teach in a school that has like 1,700
kids but i also know that my school has
built this incredible community and we
you know we have the newcomer center we
have other english-language learning
classrooms and we have a diver diversity
within our student body and we
intentionally work to ensure that our
students feel connected with one another
and when we see the
things happening these terrible where
one young person is perpetrating this
horrible crime against another young
person you have to think how why does
that kid not feel connected and and it's
not it's not it's not anybody's fault
like it's not the other students fault
that that student chose that route but
we have to be very intentional about
helping kids connect are they having the
conversation at your school about arming
teachers no oh that's not even an option
no you're not or that it's right yeah I
would prefer it not the the other
national conversation of course is about
teachers but pay you know in several
states the teachers have walked off the
jobs or protesting in the streets and
I'm wondering your opinion about that I
think we universally agreed teachers are
not paid what they deserve yeah what do
you think would be fair and I know it
ranges I get it depending on where you
live but what would be a good starting
salary and how would you like us to how
would you like to see that happen well
like you said it varies a lot I do I
have no idea what a good starting salary
is because I've taught in Texas I taught
in Washington State and I taught here in
New York City League City yeah and and
now I got paid like way more here than I
did but it was still difficult because
it's very expensive to live here so I
mean I think that you have to think
about the cost of living in an area but
more more important than the actual
number is just the idea that teachers
are not paid a professional wage and so
in and that has to do with respect and
you know treating that I mean most
teachers have to have a master's degree
to be in the classroom and so we you
know we need to be respecting that but
these these walkouts are about so much
more than engineering a it's really
about what is best for the students
because inevitably it at the heart of an
educator is the needs of our students
and that's really what they're talking
about and yes we need we do need to have
a living wage because like a
professional living wage because we we
cannot afford to have multiple jobs
because our one job with as educators is
extremely it takes so much energy
and so much focus so when we're forced
to then spend our evenings working
somewhere else or weekend's working to
take second job yes and it takes away
from our ability to focus on our kids
and that's what we all want to do we
want to focus on our kids but we also
want resources we want to have you know
functioning equipment we want to have
school buildings that are in you know
not in disrepair which by the way
doesn't seem like much to ask to do your
job it's certainly yes I like what I
said in the beginning that it really is
in many cases a level a matter of
respect yeah it is a matter of respect
I've heard you say to that hope is part
of your mission hmm
what do you mean by that so I'm gonna
get a little technical don't get too
taken I will I want just a little tiny
bit but so there's a Gallup poll that
goes out every year that asks students
their level of Hope and each year their
level of Hope is decreasing and then
they're you know there's different
things but some just feel stuck and then
some feel completely like they don't
have any hope at all yes and and that is
a huge that's a huge issue it it
definitely impacts a student's ability
to learn and then it also you know
impacts us as a society because if you
don't have hope or the feeling of agency
or autonomy that you can make decisions
for yourself and that it's going to work
out are you're gonna end up giving up
and it's really essential for us as a
society that we have hope for the future
and that we can accomplish and achieve
the things that we want to do and that
our neighbors are good people
and and that you know if we move to
another area it's going to be safe and
and and exciting and we're gonna meet
really interesting people and so I mean
your students are interesting many of
them are coming to this country they
don't speak the language I'm wondering
how you navigate talking to your
students about President Trump who some
people feel don't feel is very immigrant
friendly how do you how do you navigate
that well it's always you know aligned
because I as an public school educator I
can't influence my need to be really
careful not to influence my students but
also we're trying to get you to yet oh
yeah yeah wondering what you say to them
one within my classroom also we do have
a section of the of the refugee and
immigrant community that really supports
President Trump and his policies and
then we also have a group that is
adversely affected by his policies and
so what the the main thing that I talk
about is that our nation is much bigger
than our president and that he yes is
like the person that everybody looks to
as the person in charge of our country
but really you know the United States is
huge yeah and we're we're covered with
people and there and most people want my
students to be here they understand that
they add beauty and interesting you know
different perspectives and ideas and
that as you know as a nation who came as
immigrants we that's that's where we are
our heart is that and we will continue
to be that and my students are welcome
and they they should be here so I'm just
very intentional about sending that
message that sounds like hope to me yeah
and you will spend the next year as
Teacher of the Year 2018 traveling all
around the country spreading your
message of hope and education
Mandy Manning your name Mandy are you
familiar with the Barry Manilow song
named Andy ferry okay you gave without
taking I was when he was your real name
Amanda no it's Mandy it's Mandy cuz I
was named after that song after the very
Marilyn oh god I wish there was a way we
could play it is there any way we can
play the Barry Manilow song they're
going no it's not
all right maybe Manning thank you so
much congratulations to you
congratulations man demanding 2018
Teacher of the Year named after the
Barry Manilow song Mandy
yes